we are current in the lab as you can see
suited and booted ready to do something
very exciting hang on they're not boots
oh well suited issued as it were
we are going to doing pretty good
experiment today involving the ignition
of ice we've got trusty chemical so in
this case it's calcium carbide so it's C
a c2 and we're going to put this into a
metal tray so no glassware this time Sam
was doing a reaction of calcium carbide
it's one of these compounds that used to
be really very common but now you only
find in labs and the reason it used to
be common was that it was used for
lights for cars and also for bicycles
because in the old days beginning of the
20th century
end of xix batteries were very primitive
compared to the batteries that we have
now in mobile phones and things and so
it was very difficult to make a compact
electric light so instead people used
lamps in which there was calcium carbide
as a solid underneath and water dripped
slowly on it and generated acetylene gas
which then burnt in a small burner now
the next stage is actually rubbing lumps
of ice we're going to put the lumps of
ice on top of the calcium carbide and
they're going to react so I need to be a
bit quick with this okay we've got the
match on stick and we'll see opens
okay so what we have here is the
reaction of calcium carbide with the
water in the form of ice and we're
getting acetylene gas produced the
session for the alarm as well so the
acetylene gas c2h2 or ethan as as it's
known properly is the product of this
chemical reaction and all we've done is
just ignited but it does look as if
we've set fire to blocks of ice and
acetylene when it burns because it is a
very carbon rich compound it's c2h2
generates a lot of heat and a very
bright flame so it's not as bright as a
modern xenon headlight but in the old
days when people were used to using oil
lamps it was pretty bright and of course
cars didn't drive quite as fast as they
do nowadays and there was less traffic
so on really old cars you see these very
beautiful carbide lamps and people also
sometimes used them for caving when they
went underground but then of course
there was a danger that the flame from
the carbide lamp could ignite methane
and blow themselves up but they used
them in popped holes where you don't
normally get methane so if you find an
old adventure story about young children
you may suddenly read that they use
carbide lamps on their bicycles it's
really yeah it's a it's a cool hot
reaction it's it's great fun to do and I
think if it was the chemical stick that
was doing this he'd go bigger than this
particular trade but this is what we've
got Neil I believe I've been told is
actually off ill and I didn't think Neil
could possibly be ill because Neil is is
our chemical stick he's indestructible
more likely he's up on covert ops ok
belts I think you say yeah covert ops
definitely I only found out about this
one a few well a few months ago and I've
been waiting saving up at the right time
right moment to actually do this
reaction so it's not one I've done out
in schools or anywhere like that I think
I could do it out and about but it would
take a very understanding venue
and school to let me do this sort of
experiment I think well I think the way
they worked them was that you generated
a small pressure of acetylene which then
escaped through a pinhole to give you as
fairly steady flame and acetylene burns
with a very hot flame and nowadays for
cutting through steel bars and things
like that people still use oxy acetylene
cutters where you have a cylinder of
acetylene and gas and oxygen you mix
them together and you get very hot
flames so you can burn through metal in
fact it's quite dangerous to compress
the settling because it can explode at
high pressure so normally what happens
is that acetylene cylinders are rather
large and inside they have some material
like porous pot or brick which is
covered with acetone propanone and this
then acts as a solvent and under
pressure the acetylene will dissolve
into the liquid and when you release the
pressure it comes out so you can store
quite a large amount of acetylene
without going to high pressure as you
would with Norden Airy gas like nitrogen
or co2
we don't need to do another take do way
it seems really dangerous to me to have
this chemical reaction blazing away on
the front of your car well they were
there's only a small quantity and
probably if you crushed the car the
flame would go out anyway and old cars
were very heavy so the major danger was
the kinetic energy of this banging into
something and the fact that there was a
small flame probably didn't matter all
that much and obviously it's more
dangerous than having electrical fire
but you can if you crash a car have a
short-circuit of your battery and that
can cause a fire as well so the
take-home message was then and now you
should drive carefully and not have a
crash